i've been here since 1993 and was one of
the first few people actually on on-site
here when the original sanger institute
kicked off knowing them as the sangha
center and so i think they're about 12
or 14 people on site will actually got
here the java did then was to go to the
IT cupboard and find the first 12 small
ipx Sun ipx workstations to set up and I
think at that time there was a degree of
naivety and as many people thought that
we wouldn't need many more Sheen
machines actually to to complete the
whole human genome but i think we sing
found out there was that was not correct
so there's not only big developments in
the science but the development in IT
has really enabled the science it's been
a great enabler i remember in the early
days the head of Human Genetics David
Bentley then saying that as we as we
sequence the human genome we would need
more and more compute power to assemble
the the the genome and we would have to
use computers that were then invented
and that has been the case that
technology has advanced and and thank
goodness those advances have have helped
us to assemble the DNA human genome as
we know it today